this morning we're learning about a new
way to find and reduce greenhouse gases
that are warming our planet methane gas
which is usually invisible can actually
be seen in these infrared images and
methane by the way is much worse than
carbon dioxide when it comes to heating
up the earth a recent u.n report says it
is possible to limit warning warming
with strong rapid and sustained
reductions in methane admissions senior
national and environmental correspondent
ben tracy takes us inside a new
high-tech effort to do precisely that
[Music]
inside a hangar in boulder colorado this
appears to be just another fancy private
jet you can always pull these graphs up
but it's actually filled with scientists
on a mission to help save the planet
[Applause]
they take to the skies to hunt down an
invisible gas seen here with infrared
cameras which is rapidly heating up the
atmosphere
and fueling some of the worst impacts of
climate change
what exactly is methane methane is a
greenhouse gas it is the second largest
contributor to climate change and it
accounts for more than a quarter of the
warming that we're experiencing today
alyssa akko is a senior climate
scientist at the environmental defense
fund she says methane emissions mainly
come from leaks during fossil fuel
production from the digestive tracts of
cows when they burp and from rotting
food in landfills and here's why it
matters methane is like carbon dioxide
on steroids 84 times more powerful at
warming the planet but unlike co2 which
can stay in the atmosphere for centuries
methane only lasts for about a decade
reducing methane emissions is the single
fastest opportunity we have to slow down
the rate of warming if we're able to cut
these methane emissions what impact
would that have on on warming we have
the technologies available to cut
methane emissions globally in half over
the next 10 years and if we do that then
we can slow down the rate of global
warming by 30 percent
slowing warming could mean fewer
destructive storms wildfires and heat
waves and slower melting of the world's
ice sheets which is causing sea levels
to rise we need to know how much methane
is being emitted
from where and by whom so you actually
detect the methane through the bottom of
the plane yeah that's correct and that's
where the plane comes in up front is
actually methane air itself and if you
look up you can actually see two lenses
the scientists call it methane air
they've been flying it over what's known
as the permian basin more than 86
thousand square miles in texas the
largest oil field on the planet special
sensors on the plane detect methane
leaks from oil and gas facilities on the
ground according to the edf those
industries account for about a quarter
of all human-made methane emissions and
knowing where the leaks are can help in
identifying the polluters and holding
them responsible i see workers
capping hundreds of thousands of
abandoned oil and gas wells president
biden wants congress to spend 16 billion
dollars to help stop the methane leaks
that scientists are seeing from the air
and soon from space
a new 90 million dollar satellite called
methane sat is being built by the
environmental defense fund in part with
money from amazon founder jeff bezos
earth fund
they plan to launch it next year atop a
spacex falcon 9 rocket once in orbit it
will find and map methane leaks around
the world 24 hours a day this is the
structure steve stegg is ceo of blue
canyon technologies which is building
the satellite including the solar panels
that will act as its wings to power its
flight and so what we're seeing here
this is pretty much as big as it is and
then the solar arrays come out from
there that's exactly right this is the
size of it the solar rays will extend
out about 10 to 12 feet on each side of
the satellite so this will absolutely be
a game changer reducing planet warming
emissions has been alyssa akko's life
work since a trip to greenland during
college i watched as ice was melting off
of glaciers and just rushing out into
the ocean
and she now has one very personal reason
to work even harder i have a
two-year-old daughter
and it really worries me what the
climate will be like when she's my age i
look at my daughter every day and i just
want the best for her and a huge part of
that is the world that we're leaving
behind a world we still have a chance to
save
for cbs morning's ben tracy boulder
colorado
so what i love about that report in
addition to reminding us that cow burps
are part of global warming i i didn't
know cal's burp go ahead they do more
than burst not just the bird he left out
the second part of it it's the gas in
general in general but methane and
carbon dioxide usually invisible gases
that are warming the planet that plane
allows us to see it and if we can see it
then we can change it that's the idea
yeah and we're familiar with carbon
dioxide but methane is more potent and
powerful exactly that's a well done
piece i'm just glad people are are on
top of it and doing something about it
because i don't really think people i
think we're starting to grasp how
serious it is but i think a lot of
people don't really understand that
we're in crisis here and we need to do
something right and they're teaching
this in schools because my daughter
comes home and tells me about it all of
the time